ما مدى أهمية
مساهمات إسرائيل في التكنولوجيا غير المأهولة في هذه
المرحلة ومدى
انخراطك أو اهتمامك بهذه
القدرات الدفاعية التي يمتلك بعضها
تقنيات أكثر تقدمًا من غيرها ، إسرائيل
مثال جيد على أن لديهم بعض
التقنيات المتقدمة التي يمكنهم
استخدامها ونحن نتطلع إلى فريق  مع ذلك ،
نتطلع إلى التعاون مع الفريق الكبير
الذي لدينا بالفعل ودفع هذه
القدرة إلى الأمام من خلال
وضع المزيد من الأنظار على الماء حتى
نتمكن من رؤية ما يحدث
بطريقة أكثر حيوية مما يمكننا اليوم ،
فكيف  هل تتلاءم هذه التكنولوجيا الجديدة
مع نوع
المخزون الحالي الذي لديك ، فهو مكمل جدًا
لذلك سنستمر في استخدام
سفننا بالطريقة التي
نستخدمها بهذه الطريقة المشتركة ، حيث تعمل الأنظمة غير المأهولة الجديدة
ببساطة على زيادة هذا الأمر
ووضع أعين إضافية بشكل أساسي
على الماء بطرق لم
نتمكن من القيام بها من قبل لأن
التكنولوجيا جديدة تمامًا في بعض الحالات من ستة إلى تسعة
أشهر جديدة حيث يمكننا الآن  tain
المنصات التي في البحر غير المأهولة
لعدة أشهر في كل مرة تبحث فقط عن
المعلومات وتجلبها ،
وهنا يأتي دور الذكاء الاصطناعي في هذه المنصات ، مما
يجلب الكثير من المعلومات التي يتعين عليك استخدامها
لتحليل كل تلك المعلومات
وإحضارها إلى الإنسان  بالنسبة للقرارات ،
فإن البحرية الأمريكية تلعب دور اللحاق بالركب في هذه
المرحلة التي نقودها في هذه المرحلة ،
تحدثت البحرين
عن تعاون أو تحالف دولي لم يذكر اسمه بعد
يتألف من 34 دولة
والتي ستضم وزيرًا إسرائيليًا
هو الولايات المتحدة لنكون جزءًا من هذا التحالف
و  ما هي مهمة هذا
التحالف الجديد نعم للتوضيح هذا
التحالف يسمى
القوة البحرية المشتركة أه بالإضافة لكوني
قائد الأسطول الخامس أنا أيضًا
قائد القوة البحرية المشتركة
التي كانت موجودة لبعض الوقت إنها في
الأساس أه
يركز عليها  الأمن البحري في
المنطقة بالإضافة إلى مكافحة القرصنة ،
وأعتقد أن المهمتين تسير على ما يرام
هذه الأيام ، وأتوقع عدد
الدول في ذلك  سيتوسع التحالف هنا
في الأشهر والسنوات المقبلة ، لكن هذه
هي المهمة التي تقع في موقع مشترك داخل
مقري الخاص ولدينا هذه
البلدان الـ 34
التي تعرفها تقريبًا مثل العديد من ضباط الاتصال
وحوالي 200 شريك دولي
في المقر الرئيسي لأولئك الذين يقترحون
ذلك  الولايات المتحدة ببساطة
ليست مشاركة ولن تكون
ملتزمة بهذه المنطقة من الخليج
والشرق الأوسط الأوسع للمضي قدمًا هل تقول
ما نحن ذاهبون إلى أي مكان أه
وقيادة الأسبوع الماضي لأكبر
تمرين سنقوم به في هذه
المنطقة  مع 60 دولة أعتقد أنها دليل
قوي للغاية على
عزمنا والتزامنا
وجهودنا الكبيرة المستمرة مع جميع شركائنا في
هذه المنطقة ستزداد فقط